each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
a to introduce Daniel Wang he's uh he
has a PhD from Princeton University
working with and repelled who's a very
well-known professor of computer science
Daniel worked on garbage collection
while he was at Princeton and actually
his thesis was about trying to trying to
make the the size of the code that you
actually relied on without checking it
as small as possible and what he did was
he took the garbage collector and try to
make that into a trusted component he
then went and worked in industry for a
little while at a spin-off of Lucent
color gear and he's now back at
Princeton as a postdoc and he's going to
tell us about some experiences he's had
over the last few years Daniel also it
interned as microsoft research i guess
in 98 it was with todd probe stink so he
knows all about seattle so welcome
Daniel and soleus thank you so I had
kind of a problem I wasn't sure what
level of technical detail so if it's too
much tell me if it's too little ask
questions that I'm happy to answer them
so I want to start out with kind of
motivation so little news thing who saw
this around februari for that you know
Gosling's making wild criticisms about
holes and dotnet and the Don box of
course reporting that this is not an
uncommon phenomenon in any large
software system and in particular here
is a interesting bug i ran across
recently so i just want to point out two
things about this this is one hundred
percent pure java there's no unsafe c
code here the only odd thing going on is
we're using the reflection library and
actually particularly using this kind of
very silly method and reflection library
at let me let's meet violate the access
declarations in thing and what else have
to be using the zip deflator library
which is actually implemented native
code and because of those combinations
of using the jni interface to violate
your privacy guarantees and the way the
native code is linked to the system i
can cause it to crash the hot spot on
one windows and also on so
and also on Mac OS so this is kind of an
example that you know bugs really occur
and it's really kind of a subtle
interaction between designed reflection
API and the native interface the native
people writing the native code assume
that when you declare a field private it
actually was but the reflection API
people that's not always a good thing
because sometimes we want to serialize
the object and get out X private fields
but because of this combination you can
actually violate and crash the system
I've also verified that it will crash
into the JVM on linux x86 and again this
is because it's an issue they've the IBM
people have licensed the Solaris
libraries so the license ain't buggy
code and because it's part of the the
kind of core Jane I libraries and again
the issue is this there's a sea pointer
that's being saved in a long field of a
Java object and it's called private but
the reflection a proud lets you bypass
it and this kind of a example the bug so
again we I can't rent across this bug
when I was working with gunk on Andrew
Appel and some others at NEC we were
trying to take Java native interface
code written in C and applied George
Nicholas secured system which is a way
of taking unsafe C code and making it
safe by inserting runtime checks and we
wanted to compare the performance of the
cured C code with native Java code to
kind of you rather than so basically
have a choice of porting your unsafe C
code to pure Java to get a fully safe
system but if you want a legacy solution
that was fully say if you could have
also cure your C code with secured and
then link them together and while we
were doing that the secured system we
developed pointed this weird pointer
cast out Gong said oh this should my
systems too conservative because it
should be ok because it's declared
private in the Java object but I have
this thing against reflection because I
no reflection had this feature to let
you and violate the privacy of this
field stuff oh well I can violate that
with reflection and then kind of
demonstrate the bug from there that's
one little thing I've been working on
recently so I want to talk to you more
about you know so this kind of a state
of jvms or virtual machines in general
how could we
maybe potentially develop a fully
verified virtual machine where there are
no bugs of these sorts of it we take
care of all the interactions so I dug up
this reference someplace that basically
developing the avionics code for the
space shuttle's roughly a thousand
dollars per line so if you think about
developing code of that quality where
you're putting up a four billion dollar
mechanical system with you know half a
dozen people's lives you would hope if
you built the virtual machine that level
to quality derby no bugs in it and we
did some analysis that if you look at
the safety critical instance working the
safety critical portion of a JVM system
that's roughly 300,000 lines of code and
do the maths three hundred million
dollars if you want to develop a fully
safe virtual machine so it seems very
expensive directly verify the system to
do this so one way of making this
problem easier it is nice quote that's
an and repels webpage from Uruguay edge
of set Microsoft basically we can make
this cost cheaper by using computers to
check the proof that your system is
somehow sound this is not exactly easy
to do and we have to think about it and
doing this requires as he says in a
whole new discipline of but she's called
dance it's actually an interesting paper
about constructive logic and proof
theory but it's like one little section
in there Andrew ran across so kind of
goals of this talk is really defined my
adventures in pedantic so I'm going to
have done many pedantic things recently
and I'll tell you about them and I
really want emphasize that the challenge
once you have a clear specification
verifying something is very boring okay
the main difficulty is figuring out what
you should verify so you only verify
boring bits that are really important or
do the boring verification on the
important bits I'm going to show two
systems kind of in different ways how
you can factor them so the large parts
can be prepared automatically and I kind
of want to stimulate maybe a discussion
about you know whether software
verification is important or even
practical so i'll talk about my tie
preserving my work in kind of briefly
about technical garbage collection and
Mitch
recent work in this area this is a man
I've ever mentioned I spent two years
working at a gear doing network
processor design so kind of hanging with
hardware people and then I'll talk some
more recent work about additional proof
carrying code and kind of the goals and
what were you are on this place ok so
this is how to get a PhD in collecting
garbage so just to provide this is a
certifying compilation approach so the
first big kind of insight was kind of
made by George Nicola that if you want
to verify that native code has some
property thats related to some source
program you don't necessarily or prove
to correct this the entire compiler what
you can do is you can have this
potentially buggy compiler produce the
native code plus a bit of evidence which
is either typing derivation or a proof
and you can verify this independent of
the correctness of the compiler so if
there's a bug in this compile to produce
evidence them correspond to native code
and then your verify will catch it up
and you go fix your bug in your compiler
but you don't they verify your compiler
to guarantee that any native code that
runs has a particular property so again
the big insight is you want to separate
the witness terrific verification and
generation the compiler is generating it
may generate a buggy witness but as long
as you can guarantee the verification is
correct since a laser pointer is going
here then everything's ok so George neck
heel gave this nice talk at Princeton
then I kind of asked the question but
what about memory management how do you
deal with this because he was doing a
very simple language with arrays kind of
Fortran style code and this kind of led
to this the idea of a trusted garba so
one way you can solve this have a
trusted garbage collector so you can
imagine a scheme where you have your
native code you know garbage collector
which you verified by hand have some
property but doing this is not exactly
correct because you really have to also
trust native code is respecting all the
implicit GC invariants so for example
you have to make sure if it the GC the
native code is recording the proper live
roots there aren't using interior
pointers or not excellent point or lots
of invariants the GC needs to have
maintained by the native code to
guarantees correctly so only recently
Carl crary has divined proof
certifying compilations has been where
he can state what all the garbage
collector and variants are for least
conservative collector and he has a
proof that if you had a trusted the
collector and your code checks and you
had some guarantee that things work
properly I kind of took with different
tax so there it is in his foundational
typed assembly there's a low fees public
it was in that in that being a tech
report but he I talked to him recently
and he and his notion of a valid stating
is appropriate for a conservative GC so
at certain points in the program you're
guaranteed that all the reachable data
is actually reachable are live say all
the live data is reachable so again took
a tax similar to the initial trying to
avoid proven incorrect ins to collector
what we want to do is basically omit
some evidence for the garbage collector
we can verify and in my pictures and the
evidence of the typing type checking or
typing typing rules for the garbage
collector and what guarantees can we get
we can get that if the garbage collector
d allocates memory so I'm not
guaranteeing it actually does the alchy
any memory but if it does the allocate
any memory that memories did and we also
can get a guarantee that the garbage
collector preserves a type structure of
the value so if it's an integer it's an
integer if as an object is an object and
before and after the execution of the
collector types are preserved and since
the collector is basically now
verifiable you can kind of verify this
interface is correct that basically the
GC is calling the garbage liked with
respect to its interface with the right
set of alive roots in various things so
I don't want go to too much detail but
the main trick is basically the treat
the garbage collector as an ordinary
program even if you do that you just
have to kind of play some other games to
make this stack and routes that explicit
you apply a CPS conversion with addy
functionalization I don't want or people
with compiler optimizations today to
guarantee don'twe dead memories the
allocated we use a region type system
which is a type s'sinn the top in japan
and extended by various people so you
can reason about the safety of memory
management there's a little technical
trickery required to deal with aliasing
always an evil thing and my trick for
region aliasing was to use a dynamic
tests and the forwarding pointers were
those you're familiar with garbage
collection you typically have to leave a
little hint about where the object got
moved so you can avoid getting to
instant loop and getting with cyclic
data structures so I kind of coded
together very simple system and try to
demonstrate yet can make this practical
so the poeple pedra paper has most of
the details but I've talked about and
when numbers the hazards basically
charts so basically you can ignore this
but basically if the thing to take away
is that actually built something in it
ran I used the Milton compiler to run a
couple benchmarks using the tie
preserving collector unfortunately ran a
little slowly mainly because I
introduced an extra allocation with the
CPS conversion to make some of the stack
explicit I finally finished the thesis
which includes some extended discussion
about how to deal with some of the
performance problems associated with CPS
conversion and it's available the CSTR
so if you want to download it and read
it you can feel free to there's a big
proof at the end about various odd
things about region marant region memory
management see or some recent work I did
basically with Matt fluid oh that
Cornell was not Harvard actually so
basically a map fluid was working with
Greg Moore said on the cyclone project
and they were talking about you know
coating up a scheme interpreter and
cyclone to demonstrate how useful cyclin
was and we're curious about how if you
could write a complete scheme
implementation along with the garbage
collector and a safe dialect of skiing
of C so basically built and evaluated a
type-safe garbage collector for a scheme
interpreter by using cyclone which is a
language a lot of primitives for
reasoning about memory in a safe way so
here's the cyclone kind of sales pitch
but there's more information here but
the nice thing about cycling it really
has a lot of
mr. managing memories it has a
conservative garbage collector has a way
of reason about reference counting in a
safe way regions and a form of unique
pointer linear typing it's rich enough
to build a safe scheme interpreter we
just need one small little extra feature
to build the garbage collector for the
scheme interpreter and this is basically
dynamic region sequences and I'm going
to talk to you a little about those so
the idea of a dynamic region sequence
you can think about so you have some
region R Prime and then there's a next
region associated with it which we
denote by the region next r prime and
there's a next region after that and
with this invent you have this nice
property that if you're it if you have
some the current region in some are
prime the place where the where you're
copying the data to is always in the
next region and this simplifies some
difficult to add in the original
treatment of forwarding pointers and
kind of the invariant is as you move
between to and from space you can to
transition so you always have this
invariant to get this to work properly
we also have to add we need a notion of
a unique pointer to enforce particular
allocation protocol so we guarantee is
only exactly one next region alive any
point in the program so here is kind of
a scheme garbage collector written in
cyclone most of this is comments I don't
want to go into too much detail here
I've hidden all the really dirty work in
this zileri function here because for
the copy is this is the core allocation
in the allocation loop and if you want
some more information and suggest you
look at the paper so here's a comparison
we do in the in the paper we talk about
four different systems we talk about
cyclone a cyclone implementation of our
scheme interpreter using our typesafe
garbage collector and this is the number
of unsafe lines of code in
implementation under 0 here and the
runtime system to run this
implementation only requires about 1,800
lines of c code it's basically kind of a
fancy malik library
and we also did a comparison with
cyclone using the same interpreter the
rather than using our handcrafted
garbage collector we relied on the
standard conservative collector that
came with cyclone which is basically the
bone wiser collector and we also wanted
to compare that against a fast safe
problem tation in a language like Java
so Sisk is a scheme of implementation
that runs on the JVM it claims to be the
fastest scheme invitation out there on
the JVM and if you believe that but this
they make the claim and this interpreter
is written in Java and so there's zero
lines of unsafe codons implementation
unfortunately the runtime system is
basically all the JVM which is the JIT
compiler in the garbage collector so
that roughly you know one two hundred
thousand lines of unsafe code input the
runtime system and then we wanted to
compare against MZ scheme which is kind
of a high quality implementation of
skiing written Cooley and see so the
interpreter is unsafe it's all written
in C the runtime system is also using
the bone wiser collector so you must
want to compare these four systems and
see how they perform ok so ignore the
absolute so the relative performance is
the execution time benchmarks for a
bunch of really small standard list
benchmarks this the numbers and
parentheses are the execute our normal
lives because safe do you see here so if
you look at these numbers here you can
see that we're pretty comparable to
conservative garbage collector the bone
wise or collector for the we compared to
the java version we're you know in
something where we're doing badly in
certain cases certain cases we're going
a bit better actually and if you compare
us to be completely unsafe version we're
doing really badly except for this one
point here and this is because of the
way implements call Cece this is like a
CPS version of the tact benchmark using
call Cece and they're using the stack so
they're copying a lot here so what this
tells you is that if you just compare
the safe implementations
of the scheme interpreter we're roughly
comparable there's still a gap between
completely unsafe system because they're
done they pulled out all the stops in
some sense so there's a cost of safety
but if you are choosing between safe
systems you could say that this safe
system here has a smaller TCB than the
jvm version which is comparable
performance okay so here are some
important lessons learned about
collecting garbage you really can build
a garbage collector on simpler easier to
verify primitives you don't need to
verify the entire collector to have some
guarantee about pipe reservation at
least the main trick is you want to type
check everything including the collector
it's not this magic piece of runtime
system that's hidden in some library you
never see you should expose it to type
checker even without total correctness
we can get some interesting properties
type safety is a very useful property on
a bad thing to have and the real trick
or the real kind of exercise is really
freaking out the fact of the problem so
we can just verify the important parts
of system or systems that are relatively
easy to verify without having to verify
the whole thing okay so here's some
questions you might be wondering so we
have a really fancy type system and you
might want to wonder you know is that
really fancy type system we have bug
free so one question you might want to
ask and are the rules we're using sound
do they make sense with respect to with
semantics and is the implementation of
our type directly faceless the rules and
then another important question is
there's some corner case you can think
about and you wonder can I respect and
do with that corner case this
professional performance trick you want
to be able to do and maybe you're
texting prevents you from doing that and
in fact you can see that safety has some
performance cost mainly because we can't
reason about all the important corner
cases this kind of leads to financial
proof carrying code and some of the work
related here and basically I've been
doing a lot of very boring proofs
recently since review the certifying
compilation pipeline you have some
program with some property you run it
through something you don't trust and
you verify at the very end and then the
natural question to ask is this is a
verifier bug free
so what does the verifier consist of
well basically has to consist of a
policy specification machine semantics
so we have to understand what it means
to execute something in the machine some
semantics for your type system and then
a very simple checker just completely
dying on me so I'll try this instead
you're both dead okay yes I think it's
flaky the checker and it turns out in
the original at PCC systems there were
whole set of obvious lemmas about how
certain things were true obviously and
it turns out her some bugs here not very
often so the question of the foundation
approve carry encode project is how can
we reduce this to the bare minimum and
basically it was what i mean by the bare
minimum well if you think about it you
can't really avoid this you know you
have to have a policy specific it you
have to have a specification before you
can verify anything so you have to the
policy is part of the TCB machine
semantics are part of the policy in some
sense and so the type of semantics and
the checkers but these lemmas can
actually be written in the form a candy
machine check so we don't trust them
anymore so right now the these lemmas in
the current princeton pc framework
around hundred thousand lines of proof
and their machine checked so the current
PCB sides at the for the princeton
project work now is around three to five
thousand lines of code depending on the
specific policy you use so if your
policy is very expressive and just gets
bigger if it's really simple i'll get
smaller
so this is a project started in 1999
quite old actually and I just kind of
saw the beginnings of it I was leaving
Princeton and graduating part of the
project system certifying compile for
standard ml or gin gin and have
contributed to in the audience a type
checker expressed as a bunch of horn
clauses about reasoning about what's the
valid typing let's type safe or not
machine semantics for the spark ridden
high high order logic and the Shane
check proof that the type of rules used
are correct and the proof verifier which
is actually written in about under a
thousand lines of c code so I'm going to
delete awk about some of the proof
techniques we used in the rest of the
talk and this is here where people can
feel free to tell me from telling them
too much or too little so I'm going to
talk about this slightly controversial
issue of semantics techniques versus
syntactic techniques controversy on the
poeple community at least so the
foundational proof carrying code project
uses what we call cinematic techniques
as opposed to more traditional syntactic
techniques unfortunately the big proof
of working has evolved there were
several iterations and because of that
their artifacts and their little
confusing so haven't spent some time
trying to work on the real proof I've
also spent some time trying to extract
from it a small little proof I could
explain to someone and so the techniques
are using are pretty clear and I'm going
to kind of sketch or remind you of some
techniques are and also talk about
semantic approaches and try to clarify
some issues and then I'm going to kind
of summarize and talk a little about
other pc related research
how am I on time what yeah okay okay I
can take some time here then so this is
just the standard semantics for these
simply for the untyped lambda calculus
and call by value of framework so this
curious how many people the audience can
read this and be bored by it ok ok so
the lambda calculus k so let's start
with the so this is the language of the
lambda calculus it's basically we have
function at function body this is a
variable being bound in the body of a
function these are high order functions
a first class right this is the
application of some expression to
another expression a variable or integer
constants here and the values these are
the things that programs evaluate to are
either functions or just integers sorry
think this is a function this is a
function whose input input variable is
called X and X occurs in the body of you
someplace right basically if you were
doing if you if this was code yeah yeah
and see this would be like this a bunch
more tea ice it just doesn't have a name
right right right right right right it's
funny my manners x got it and his body's
eat
so this is basically defining by
induction a relation of step relation
that tells you when one program when
when one expression steps to another so
this is the case where we have a
function applied to a value and we're
going to step to the body of the
function this is a notation for
substitution so I'm going to take every
occurrence of X in e1 and replace it
with me so when i'm applying a value to
function we just do this rule atomically
so if i have oats the slight bug in
these rules but ok this is fine it just
should be V I just realized that but if
I have a an expression it looks like
this where this is a value and this is
some other expression e to I can reduce
it in one step to basically this this
argument unchanged this has been
modified and this has been modified in
the following way it takes a step this
basically says left right evaluation so
evaluate the the left component of the
application all the way to a value and
then reduce this and when this becomes
the value than this will apply and this
is the other case where we just evaluate
e1 first we already talked about how
but this is in the end verification
right so it seems like there's things
they are we talking about something that
you have to test in a way to test it or
are we not just giving romantics for the
machine so here's the Madeira here's a
language it has some meaning as
semantics to it and the next thing I'm
gonna talk about what it means to be
what property were going to verify that
ok so the ill notice if you look at this
this relation is partial so for example
if you try to reduce an integer apply to
an integer you get stuck there'd be no
rule that would apply because the only
will these always have to be functions
in the net prime location okay so okay
so this is a single-step relation it
tells you when one expression takes one
step and we can define from this
multi-step relation saying any
expression steps to itself in zero steps
and expression steps to eat it will
prime in n plus 1 steps if it takes one
small step and then that resulting
expression steps are anymore so
basically we can talk about an
expression taking n steps to another
expression and we can define a notion of
a term being safe if for any n if e
reduces to e prime then e prime can take
a step or as a value that means if I
have an expression and I can do any
number of reductions to it that final
expression is either a value or it can
make progress so for example this
expression is safe because basically
you're applying 02 identity function
here reduces to the value zero this
expression I know this is kind of a if
you're familiar the lambda calculus this
is the kind of standard looping lambda
expression so if you if you apply the
substitution rule to this expression you
get it back again so this kind of
reduces through so sorry
this this one right here that relation
that I didn't finish the term is safe if
then e prime takes a step or Isabel what
does it mean the existing this text
artist Texas that means there exists
some base region the e prime is there
exists on other eat double promise in
this relation here the single-step
relation it doesn't take a stick no way
does it is saying this is safe because
of the for any production there's always
one more step you can't act so it loops
it safe because it loops forever this
could we not safe because there's no
stepping today so every non termine
expression is safe because it always
eight step this is safety 200 right this
is a value this is safe because of loops
forever and this is not safe
top natural numbers income so there's
any function is the value something to
be a first-class
ok so for additional type system so this
is claimed what you should be jealous or
something go sorry what did you sky is
it yes yes standard call-by-value tool
and make healthy food natural numbers so
given this definition of safety here
with a little thinking you can convince
yourself it's undecidable because it
results it evolved determination
basically I can if I can you can reduce
it to a termination problem so safety in
general is undecidable but to establish
safety in a kind of automatic way or
using type systems we can interest a
conservative approximation basically a
typing a type system and its
conservative in the sense that if the
system says it's un-- sorry it's
conserved in the sense that if you have
an unsafe term it will not be mistaken
for a safe term but it will reject
certain terms which are safe but not
necessarily type safe okay
occupation okay what is a bit about this
not safe to think critically of them
won't say okay I I would expect the city
style take me she looks to be an unsafe
so this is an example of a it is not a
formal just motivation okay so most type
systems are specified first you to find
a relation of this form and you notice
this relation is a partial relation in
particular this is not allowed this is a
type error in the semantics because
semantics get stuck so if we know what
program is not stuck then we know there
are no type errors in it whether you're
the second class don't occur
you did not say
this is not safe because I ok I just it
for this week ok so what is
oh you might say this especially right
right it doesn't make sense to apply 0
to a non function so you encode type
errors as making your reduction relation
basically there's some property you want
to enforce you encoded you make sure
your separation get stuck when that
property violated and then you develop a
hyphen from the guarantee that never get
stuck and every of a guarantee so like
for instance suppose you want to enforce
in a program that you never write to a
closed file okay then you can imagine
encoding that in such a way that if you
ever try to write or close by and you
get dr. that's enough and so
mathematically what you'd be trying to
do is find your program whether you
could get stuck like this that would
mean you're writing to most part which
is the real thing you want to check
ok
this one area so every kind of explained
to you traditional approaches to the
pipe down kind of standard textbook well
not exactly textbook but close to
textbook so this is a traditional type
system for the simply typed lambda
calculus or one of them you can invent
for it so we introduce a new concept of
typing environment so we keep track the
types of variables free variables so for
example n has type natural for any
context a variable has some type tau
depending on what it's type is in the
context oh sorry that's a typo to never
know I these are the slides I never look
at because they're all one is always
boring this should you don't have to
explain yeah okay so you should read
this as assuming the bindings of
variables two types in gamma you can
show that n is sorry some expression has
some type so for example if I have an
application of e1 to e2 if I know under
the same set of assumptions that e1 has
an arrow type is a function from t1 to
t2 and each you has type t1 which is the
right type for this expect expectation
then when I apply e two to e 1 out
results in an expression of type T to
right and this is the rule for type
checking the body of a function so here
you assume that X so if you if you claim
if you want to share that this function
this function has type t1 arrow teach
you you assume in your environment that
X has type tau which should be tau 1 I
hopefully hate this this should be tau 1
and try to type check the body at e 1
under that assumption there should be a
towel one here I'm sorry about that
it's one particular type the type of
natural so there's a team to finish your
lunch I've so yeah so this is the type
for either natural or functions on
Nettles we're functions on functions on
natural
so once you have all this definition of
the relations you prove a standard type
safety theorem and the type to
experiment if e is well type under no
assumptions and for any type tial than
esa that means it always makes progress
for is a value foods to a value you just
by induction the structure of the
multi-step relation with progress and
preservation lemons the progress lemon
basically says or any well typed
expression and it either takes a step or
it's a value okay and you do prove this
by induction on the typing rule the
definition of the relation and
preservation says if e takes a single
step 2 e prime and ii happen to be well
typed a type tao originally then e prime
is also well type dat towel so basically
as you reduce an expression of type of
expression isn't change in any well
typed expression but always to make
progress or the value and with these two
lemmas and this you can prove type 50
theorem okay
so for example the type system i showed
you would accept this program right here
that zero applied at any function is
well-formed it rejects this because
there are no typing rules that apply to
it and this happened to be unsafe it's a
good thing unfortunately this particular
system is in sufficiently powerful to
type check this term so even though we
know this is a safe term because it's
non terminating the type system i showed
you can't type this term in fact
actually the type system i showed you
here is only able to type check terms
that always terminate so these are only
the strongly normalizing type save terms
in some sense and the real problem with
the kind of syntactic approaches because
they're very successful otherwise is
that adding kind of special case to
handle this term has a global
consequence the structured additional
proof we have to you look at here we're
kind of providing doing induction over
the structure of the definition and when
we extend this relation to add an extra
case we have to kind of reconsider our
proof and it's just kind of a proof
maintenance nightmare so the FPC
semantic approach is really trying to
get the same guarantees of safety but
we're going to factor the problem in a
different way I'm going to try to
improve the modularity of the proof sure
okay so
you save
step it takes establish where right does
it mean the something which is two steps
books room from an unsafe still be safe
I said okay any poor presume you so type
settings a stronger property than right
i mean the visa if I need for something
like the
take like five steps to
reduction step to arrive to do and safe
they're like 00 it is still safe for
your definition right you're actually
alluding to what I'm going to show you
next but I just wish so there's there
two issues there's type safety and
safety okay so you can say that a term
may be safe for five steps because for
five steps doesn't get stuck in your
definition right the definition
so it is unsafe it is why exhibit zero a
month time right but if after I apply
one reduction step I like 200 it's still
safe right because of this oh no no no
so the definition of safe here is so if
you have some expression and if for some
number of reductions there so basically
any possible reduction so so yeah pick a
kicker you know so basically any think
of the chain of possible reductions pick
any beginning reduction and that point
can always make progress basically
saying the chain is infinite or a value
okay okay so here it might get even more
technical but you click but I just don't
get it emerges but i would say that
people save this boot if you'll adjust
production paradoxical
do but so this is a gator logician
you're very happy if you're a programmer
and want to write a program that
actually doesn't terminate for whatever
reason or loops or is recursive you have
a problem
right ok so just soon yeah so I just
miss you need illustration of how type
systems are always conservative in some
way in a very simple system conservative
and kind of annoying so you'll discover
if you develop type systems that every
year is a new one it is a new one
because the old ones rejected something
that someone cared about so you're
always constantly extending the types of
student go for it more and more
realistic cases so here is kind of the
distillation of the FPC project
hopefully in one slot almost there's a
machine here's a different definition of
typing relation so we're going to say
for example naturals our halfpipe nap
and we're going to save some expression
E has type cow if he happens to take a
step since I'm p prime and e prime
happens to have typed out and the typing
rule here for functions are complicated
but you think about what it means it
says I play I have some function with
some parameter X and I claimant has type
1 type how one Eric out too
that should be the case if give me any
value of type Cal one now if I replace X
for that arbitrary value in E if that
resulting substitute expression where
every cons of X replaced with v has
typed out too and if if you assume this
and you could if you can show this is
true then you can show that the function
is in the typing relation so another way
of thinking about it is a canonical
value basically a value with a certain
structure so a type-safe express eight
if you have a canonical value I mean
it's a value of a certain structure or
you have an expression that reduces to
another tech tip expression then that
expression is type safe so there's one
problem that missing the induction step
yes yes yes there's no induction
principle here that makes relation
well-defined and this is the magic trick
the index model so this was worked by
and repelled and David Callister to deal
with issue of the cursive types but the
general technique they talk about is
applicable to any kind of strange
recursive definition so you can
generalize the index model and in fact
it's the index models used the indexes
are used in two places in our current
proof to save our save our bacon making
things work and I realize that oh wow
this is actually the real thing that
makes everything work is seen its index
model so here is kind of the indexed
approach so rather than talking about
typesafe we talk about type safe to give
an approximation so for example n is
type safe for arbitrary approximation
meaning that for you can think of it
it's types its type safe for I
reductions or I observations so you can
put this in the context and you can
reduce it for arbitrary never and then
we'll notice the sting assure them here
so here here's the induction printable
you say an expression E is typesafe 4i
plus 1 steps if e takes a step 2 e prime
any prime is typed it for I steps and
now we have a wealth well defined
induction principle here and for the
function definition here this is it I
plus 1 and we're taking the
approximation here I and if you think
what's going on here it went to apply
the function you have to consume a step
this works out nicely so now I see why
you've made that just balls directories
question because Grigori was getting at
I'll follow you all right right right or
something bad all right round as worked
so basically we can talk about your this
far away from something bad and if you
even prove that you're arbitrarily far
away from something bad right so this is
the key insight in the foundational
proof carrying coats name this is
actually so if you're flumist semantics
people have tried to address these
problems the main injury and everything
but this kind of fell out as a very
simple way of doing it and it was kind
of a when you're right a proof on a
paper and pencil proof you have all
these wonderful theorems that other
people have developed for you and you
don't care how complicated they are you
just use them when you're formalizing
everything from scratch you're really
looking for the simplest solution
because you can't cheat everything has
to be coded up so I think some of the
insight from the foundation proof can
encode project kind of applying
semantics in a practical way and
discovering that oh there are there like
proofs on paper and pencil that are very
hard to translate the mechanical systems
so you kind of spend some time thinking
about how to make it easy
it's a sort of related with blood
correlations yeah it's a general is it
so the logical relation you're using
type structure is new induction
principle here we're using something a
little step I took a slide out but you
mentioned it so traditional semantic
speaks are using the type structure of
the induction principle this slide was
motivated because when you start talking
about recursive types your type
structure is now infinite you can't
really use that inductor principle and
if you read mad hops thesis on plan
norfolk referenced in the polymorphism
mutable references he makes this comment
that there's not a really good duction
principle when you have heaps and stores
and everything and it's because the type
structure really isn't the right
structure to induct on and the step-step
relation has been very robust been able
to use that too so basically the indexes
were introduced to deal with recursive
types when we did mutable references it
turned out oh there was one place in the
middle reference people we need an
induction principal and the stepford
delay the step induction actually work
with also and if we were ducking in the
struck go ahead after the bright should
personality that's what we do that's how
you feel abstract interpretation of us
out right you take the step and you do
induction on the step when you do that
the fixed point O
take lots of magnetic stuff right right
but I perform but the semantics aren't
we formalized to operational semantics
so that's kind of most of the videos we
maybe should talk up Flanders oops wrong
button here okay okay so you ok so
now given this definition here that's
now is well defined by because of the
index I can prove the site safety team
in a very direct way because basically
the definition to relation almost says
if you're typeset or your type C for
arbitrary I then you're safe could you
always can take a step basically almost
by definition this is where the easy bit
comes in the real work is to prove these
lemmas where we'd find a new notion of
being type safe with respect to some
environment for arbitrary number of
steps so you should read this as here's
some assumptions about the types of your
variables Sigma as a substitution never
takes every variable to some arbitrary
value and we can say that substitution
is well is is well played this excess of
every variable in the substitution is
well typed a well-formed some
approximation high and since the
resulting expression with all the
substation supply and you basically can
prove these inference rules which are
basically one to one to the original
increased rules from these definitions
so here's a very technical detail ok so
actually the other thing we can prove we
can prove by induction that this term
has it has any type for arbitrary number
of steps it is kind of a national thing
to expect that a nonterminating term can
have be assigned any type for any number
of steps
so the one thing we lose in semantic
approach the permeable syntactic
approach we typically have an inversion
principle where you know that well if e1
and e2 is our well type that tattoo then
it must be the case that e1 had some
function type we lose these principles
in the in the semantics because we don't
have we're not computing the least
relation we solution to a bed of
equations we just have some model that's
consistent with the typing rules but it
may not be the least model so therefore
we can't convert the rules but this is
not a really a problem because we don't
need them anymore you did a critical
improving progress and preservation in
this intact for Sophie have safety of
another way okay so here's actual the
real proof formalized in higher order
logic encoded in LF I just want to show
it to you to kind of give you a flavor
what it looks like or bits is the end of
the real truth exactly the final so for
example it here's what the show to you
that this program prg is safe where the
program is actually an interesting
program here it's the ok so the identity
function is just did any come from here
this is the identity function apply to 0
so that's 0 to apply to any function
Omega here is our non terminating term
and here is the program we're going to
show is safe it's the identity function
apply to 0 feedback you applied to Omega
apply to an unsafe term so this term
right here would not be type checkable
in the previous and the simply
traditional approach because it's not
well type it every sub term but you can
kind of argue that I don't we care about
this this is a nonterminating term going
to get that reduction does is safe
so here's the typing this is a proof
that the identity function is well typed
this is a proof that the identity
function applied to 0 was well typed and
this is the proof of the program this
program humid well type and it's
composed by using this rule for
confining the derivation for application
for the application between you're
applying two terms so I can show this
sub term is well type and share that sub
term as well type I'm happy I show this
sub term as well type by using this
typing rule it's basically i'll show you
later says that if a program is provably
divergent than its type safe and then
from here i can just convert the proof
of type safety and safety with this
judgment this is kind of a few flavor
what the actual you know anybody looks
like
so here is actually this particular ad
hoc rule would approve so I'm going to
find additional divergence something the
Verge's if for any end to start
multi-step relation if it takes a step
for arbitrary and eeprom then there
sorry for any end of this another step
you can take this what it means to
diverge this is the important thing to
note but just as a user of the rule you
can just read it this way if I can prove
eat the burgers then it has a type or
arbitrary nnt and you really don't need
to know about what's going on there
because it's machine check and it's kind
of these are actually much easier to
write and read it's a problem for me
it's actually it's much easier to write
the really unintelligible proof it's
much I'm our obtained to maintain that
maintain that roof anyways so I don't
know okay this is even more technical
thing but kind of a motivation for this
is the current proof system we're using
right out in Princeton is using first
order encodings of binding so this
isn'ta brought in to see the explicit
environments and if you ever program
these in a trial that a real pain to get
right and i was sponsored for writing
some rule about substitution and abroad
and see is improving them correct and
was really really pouring and I knew
about high over Africa syntax of this
approach that's been used in a lot of to
improvement communities and I wanted to
use that and I asked Andrew so why
didn't you use high order up some tax
and his answer was I didn't I wasn't
sure it would work and I thought about
it and I think it should work so I've
been spending some time trying to build
demo of this and so I'm trying to build
a complete and then demo of this very
simple calculus i showed you right now
and again if we want to know i can i
have i have proofs to show you okay so
it just kind of summarize the advantage
of the semantic approach i think the
real thing is it's adding an how cruel
system is easy it's not this
carefully craft relation that you know
if you add an extra rules can destroy
your properties it's kind of this
general framework though the standard
techniques are not as modular and with
semantic approaches that you can build
verification systems in a modular way
because the program semantics is the
truth you know there's nothing to argue
about you know the program behave a
certain way and you either prove a
property about it or not the syntactic
approach a large fishel in some sense
but of course there are also other valid
competing approaches and this one is
going to give you a short see
bibliography so the most recent work who
is this open verifier that george neck
deal has been working on with an TLD i
recently he is generalizing the original
foundation reveal proof carrying code
project into a more foundational flavor
before that there was paper I call of
credit which I mentioned earlier and he
uses a traditional syntactic technique
to prove type safety with a different
logical framework getting in there was
another traditional syntactic approach
financial approve Karen code using it
another logical framework and you have
another system and then finally this is
the kind of the earliest survey paper
about publishing preparing for the end
read written you know the project
started in 99 to some earlier papers but
this is a good survey of everything
the kind of lessons learn so
foundational verification important
properties of dyspraxia verifying that
beloved machine code is actually easy I
mean it's been done by a bunch of
academic so it must be easy right there
really are at least four independent
approaches it all work I think they all
work at key points in the design space
and is most of the kind of fights we're
having these are engineering questions
about how the proof should look you know
there's really on any fundamental
problems to this there are a lot of
engineering challenges and there are a
few I think they're our favorite color
to semantic questions that are open but
I think we can do it I make us kind of
claim that for a several million dollars
not 300 million but you know several
million you can build a verified via and
this kind of the things to think about
this when it closes some thoughts I
think they're I think they're clear
there are many useful tools out there
for verification of software and the
real challenge they think is to improve
the tools proving tools not a business
or important thing to do we also have to
kind of learn to apply the mint elegy in
the right part of the system because I
think this is something as a little
maybe a little controversial to say but
I think right now the way tools are used
are too kind of make products better by
getting rid of the bugs if you really
think about it you could use
verification to kind of open up new
businesses and markets if i can make
again or you can use it a marketing
strategy i have warrantied software i
have software that's guaranteed to be
bug free for a certain class of bugs
your competitors don't you know and as
the customer do you buy this code of the
warranty or not so that's a way of
differentiating your product in a very
significant way I go to Lloyd's of
London and I say look we have its due
the following formal verification
framework is following across the
software development and we're
guaranteeing against this class of bugs
we can help me buffer overruns that the
colonel is buffer overrun flea free and
you talk to the insurance companies and
they say okay if you can ensure you
against this will you pay this much and
will guarantee that much right so I mean
it can be done I mean loads of fun to
insure anything right and it's a
question of the cost of insurance and
that's
I personally will to pay significant
money to those who will find bugs in the
program that you guarantee to the Nomad
right right so yeah yeah that's one way
you've been kind of a bug bounty
approach or again if you have a proof
that something is true then you can be
felt even warranty or however you want i
mean it's proof mistakes about in the
roof like dead see us after it was
possible abolished right right right
that's the issue here is that these
proofs are talking about the ones i've
showed you ever machine checkable these
aren't paper and pepper proof but you
can make mistakes running those poor
little slow machines we check your
google play yes so so there's a whole is
a whole issue of assurance so the way
our system is structured right now that
the minimal verifier is thousand lines
of c code duty six page
yes oh yes I shouldn't eat people food
insurance companies right right all
famous of pros are ya all all statements
through thurs level the shirts though
the way I say is how much you're willing
to bet you know some things do that over
lunch sometimes you'll bet your life on
it's the case that people buildtech the
safety critical software which is much
bigger than people are going to put
their lives on so we should build a bed
a few million dollars on on some claims
anyways so it's all we had to say I've
been questioned them to talk about my
heart have a question so is it possible
to apply these kind of tight Proops to
encryption algorithms and to somehow
prove that an encryption algorithm may
be so difficult to break okay so there
are two issues so encryption algorithms
that's the p equals NP so the answer is
no but there are if there are work who
are analyzing christian protocol so I
have some protocol encryption protocol
so you can be very complicated some key
exchange protocol and if you make some
assumptions about how the cryptography
works there are formal verification
framework you can verify your protocol
like in the there's no attacker that can
inject a message that caused your
cortical to miss authenticate you and I
think there's some recently some work by
Benjamin Pierce who was saying
let's take you of program your you want
to get just an abstraction property that
your program can't look at this data
okay and you can prove this formally
assuming some type system and he has
some way of taking that type based
argument and turning it into a
cryptography based argument saying as
long as you keep this code encrypted
during this part of the program then the
program's behavior is independent of the
actual data underneath it has been some
ways of so cryptography it's the
question about other one-way functions
or is P equal to NP we don't know but
there are definitely some ways of using
formal techniques to leverage the
protocol process which is can be very
error-prone also
oh thank you and thank you